[Music]
[ __ ]
the our place ticket Laird
no okay so just don't wait call thank
you Wow
nice suit visit Stanley
[Music]
oh Jesus
oh that's not good
no no no oh you're not gonna walk that
one off
oh that's a grouse oh I'm so sorry
all right I got spent way too long in
the phone booth if I'm being honest with
myself I'm probably should have just
called 911
well matters now if I read your both
there's a real ploy here oh [ __ ] is a
phone be doing on a street corner
disappearing any a pose we could excuse
myself
whew and jerry garcia ice cream you need
this
don't answer this trash we actually i
made a call to the costumer his name is
layer usually helped me put the suit on
the other guys do so quickly he probably
wouldn't be dead if it was Logan you got
to change into there was a [ __ ] tank
top of the pair of jeans yeah
longest get my tank top own beautiful
inspiration given electric Quran
fighting for a year at the hug equality
this is so great so we got to break this
down dead bulletin teaser almost a year
in advance of the movie coming out oh my
god this is so great so you may detected
that when he walks in with the hoodie on
it's actually the song from the credits
in the first set full movie the angel of
the morning song the story at the end of
the credits when the scroll is playing
is actually the song from true romance
so they're just teasing cable and
Deadpool romance stuff happening in the
next movie obviously they're not going
to be actually romancing each other but
the working title of the movie is called
Love Machine so there's just all kinds
of jokes going on about the two of them
pairing up together so there's a new
brand of the Logan giveaway just because
this is so awesome
I'm giving away two imax gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber we have a comment
about Deadpool on this video so there
are a whole bunch of Easter eggs about
this so you detected the Superman vibe
he's totally making fun of Superman
phone booth didn't those go out of style
in 98 the theater behind him is playing
Logan I mean this is like Skid Row it's
like the worst looking neighborhood ever
but he's changing in the phone booth you
see on the side here says Nathan summers
is coming there's even hope scrawled on
the back for hope and cable in the
Messiah Complex storyline I love that
Easter Egg but I'm not expecting that
hope is going to be in the Deadpool
movie I think it's just a wink at hope
and cable I talked a little bit about
the story that they're going with
they're going to do something original
but it'll be the first time the cable
and Deadpool meet on screen so there'll
be a lot of comic book Easter eggs for
New Mutants 98 their first run and
you'll probably see some Easter eggs for
the first time the cable appeared in the
comics he appeared as a baby in uncanny
x-men a long time before he became the
Cable character like the Cable character
was created by Rob Liefeld but the
Nathan Sommers character was created by
Chris Claremont in the uncanny x-men
title so cable debuted a new mutants but
Nathan summers debuted like way before
that in uncanny x-men way back behind
him on the wall as he's running you see
a firefly poster that was the Fox
property that got canceled so this is
all Fox stuff and if you wonder why
they're able to use the John Williams
theme song it's because the producer of
all these x-men movies Laura Shula
Donner is married to Richard Donner
whose company produced the Superman
movies so they might have some sort of
backdoor rights access to that but they
finally put Stan Lee in this version
when people went to see it in the
theater he wasn't in that version that
played ahead of the Logan movie so I
didn't see it but I knew that he was in
here somewhere
zip it Stan Lee so glad to see he's
going to be somewhere in this movie they
also added st. Elmo's fire to this
version when he's charging to save the
guy who's already been killed there's a
whole story about the creation of this -
but it's mostly meant to hype up
Deadpool stuff happening early next year
because they're going to try and drop it
sometime February March just depending
on when they get the movie started once
you finish a movie they can turn it
around in as little as six months but it
just depends on when they finish
shooting Deadpool so they really want to
get started so there's going to be a
bunch of awesome Black Panther Deadpool
stuff happening at the beginning of next
year
you seriously won't have to wait this
long it's going to be great let me know
in the comments if you spotted any other
Easter eggs I'm sure there's a bunch of
graffiti here as we pick through this
over the next year or so till Deadpool
actually gets here seriously it's like a
year away so they're releasing this just
to remind you that something really cool
is on the way I totally love that they
attach this to the beginning - it
would've been totally inappropriate at
the end of Logan it would have
completely undermined that film and if
you haven't seen it yet you have to go
see Logan this weekend hands down best
x-men movie if not best comic book movie
of all time
what's going on right now with dead for
though is that they're locking down
their cable actors they'll find dominoes
then they'll find their supporting cast
and they'll start shooting really soon
they've almost found their cables so
that was like the last couple picks so
they'll probably confirm who he's going
to be in the next week or two but it's
seriously right around the corner so let
me know what kind of Deadpool videos you
guys want me to do there's been all
kinds of great comic book stuff
happening but there has been a whole lot
of movie stuff happening lately
until now so just drop this bomb like oh
surprise here you go so it's totally
awesome I totally love with boxes doing
to market this what's going to happen is
in the next couple days I'll post my
Logan Easter eggs then I'll talk some
more about the future of Deadpool the
future of the x-23 character what they
might do with the Wolverine character in
future movies but like I said it's going
to be a while before we see Wolverine
again so this wasn't awesome enough I've
also got some new
the Thrones Season seven footage that
I'm going to be posting in a couple more
hours so full bunch awesome stuff
happening this weekend probably going to
go see Logan again for a third time what
are you wait for that you can click here
to learn all about cable and you can
click here for my Logan review video
thank you so much for watching what I
thought I'll see you guys in the next
video